well as we mentioned the uk has recorded
the highest number of new
cases since the pandemic began another
33
470 people have tested positive for
covid
in the uk that's a rise of more than ten
and a half thousand
from yesterday's figure it comes as a
large study has found that the uk's
coronavirus outbreak is continuing to
expand rapidly
imperial college london has found that
more than 1 in 80 people in england now
has the virus compared to one in
170 at the start of october our
technology correspondent roland manthorp
is uh with me so a role in a large rise
in cases but tell us more about the
these figures you have from imperial
college
yes i mean so imperial college has got a
really
big influential study they tested 160
000 people between the 16th of october
and the 2nd of november and i mean
looking at this data it's a bit like
watching a movie where you know the end
i mean we all know
how this ends up we all know that we end
up
back in lockdown but it gives us a sense
of the plot of what happened leading up
to lockdown and it is incredibly
interesting
so we started off and as you were saying
there was a very big rise
in mid to late october we the virus was
doubling
and almost a hundred thousand new
infections were happening
every single day then the researchers
found
things plateaued off a bit right up
until
the end of october and this is when
things get very interesting
the scientists found that right across
across the country
there was a sharp little uptick just
before
we went into lockdown and we had a
briefing call with them earlier
and it was put to them was this
expectation of a lockdown sending people
out to the pub
and they said they couldn't be sure but
it's quite
possible that was the case i mean
we've been hearing all day all day today
and all day yesterday
about lee kane the prime minister's
chief
spokesperson and his shock resignation
reportedly
because of tensions because of that leak
it felt
incredibly significant at the time but
now we learn
that that leak which uh put news out
about about lockdown before it's ready
to be announced
may have also caused a spike in cases
going into this lockdown which could
help explain
why as we heard today cases are still
at a very high level it felt like an
incredibly
consequential moment at the time now we
learn
that it was perhaps even more
significant than we thought yeah
uh interesting stuff roland thanks for